and your diamondback starting picture
tonight the youngster roberto castiano's
23 year old right hander he has kept the
opposition to just three runs guns
though in each of his last three starts
he's done pretty well
reaches out and pokes it to first
christian walker's there and castellanos
with a bit of a bumpy ride not super
sharp but a zero goes on the board
diamondbacks coming up against john gray
john gray out on the hill for
his 29th and final start of the season
3-2
strike three called got the running
fastball on the outside edge of john
tumpain's strike zone and john gray
starts it off with a strikeout
2-2 is strike three called under the
hands on the inside corner and martay
didn't like that call
john gray starts off with a pair of
strikeouts
martay stood at home plate for more than
a moment
there's another breaking ball and it
gets by martay through the hole on the
right side
ryan mcmahon with a base hit and the
rockies have two on and nobody out here
in the top of the second two on one out
here's the 3-2 ball four sam draws
another walk and now the bases are
loaded for
[Applause]
took a gray
and castianos gets his first strikeout
tonight and more importantly his second
out and now it's toppy with a leadoff
man two away and a ground ball to first
easy play for walker at the back steps
in the bag and that'll retire the side
so the rockies threaten two hits a walk
in the inning they leave them loaded
well john gray has struck out three of
the first four he's faced a slider there
he got cole calhoun just a good slider
he sold it with the arm speed right
there just buried it down and into that
left-hander that's a tough swing right
there your back foot
[Applause]
96 inside gray has already punched out
four
gray on the 2-2
and a fly ball shallow left topia on on
on and can't get it
and it bounces in front of him
for a base hit and gray
not too happy out there on the mound he
went
basically bent over
and straightened back up he thought that
ball should have been caught
mccarthy on the move pardomo gets into
one
along the line for blackman and he won't
get there jake had to hold up just to be
safe and perdomo's got the double
mccarthy wasn't sure if blackman would
get there had to stop just to be certain
but he got into third no problem now the
dive backs with two guys on and
castiales is licking his chops coming to
the plate
castillano says he's a hitter and he
drives one out of here it's gone
humberto castellanos and it's three
nothing diamondbacks
he has consistently told tori lavella
look skip i can hit i played third base
in mexico let me swing it
how about that boy he hit that on a line
that was a rocket getting out of here
look at him and that brings up martay
there's a high drive to right that ball
is going to go blackman gives it a look
long gone home run marte four nothing d
backs two home runs in the inning
that was the no doubter variety
jumped all over that one a fastball and
105 miles an hour later that's halfway
up the bleachers
dalton pokes one into left field that
drops
in that's five hits in the third inning
against john gray he got peralta's last
time up on that comebacker starting at
peralta's right hip
that's a fair ball down the line varsity
is on the run
dalton varsio coming around third here's
the throw
hey is in there
it rolls away from diaz
and peralta's in at third it's five
nothing diamondbacks
there's that speed dalton varsio
the diabax now have a five run third
inning and a five nothing lead walker
drills it deep to right field is this
number three
that's gone
christian walker a home run three home
runs in the third for the diamondbacks
the dude in the taco hat caught it
and that's number 10 for christian
walker
call
strike three
eight straight set down by castiano so
you talk about a shutdown inning that
was it sevens in diamondbacks brandon
rogers will lead things off in the sixth
brendan a single and a strikeout against
castellanos and he's got himself another
hit
that's good it's about the same spot he
hit the ball
[Applause]
in the first inning kind of fastball up
they sit by charlie charlie beat the
shift brendan will stop at second cj
crone a single in two tries
and this is gonna sneak through rockies
may get on the board brennan rogers is
going to come home
the throw will go to third and cj crone
has his 91st rbi nice job coming back
from an o2 count and it's 7-1 ryan
mcmahon
a personal high in rbis with 85.
he's gonna drop
and the rockies will get another run as
blackman scores
it'll be a fly ball double for mcmahon
seven to two
and another rbi for mac too oh that that
was funny do you see what marta did time
was called
he tried and and mcmahon was giving his
equipment
to the ball boy
well i guarantee you for a second he got
mack too elias diaz with a solid single
someplace could add a few more for the
rockies
this ball's hit hard through the left
side
mackel stop at third it is now seven to
three on the base hit by diaz as crone
scores the only thing that's missing
right now is a home run so it'd be just
like the
third inning for the diamondbacks still
just one out three runs in first and
third sam hilliard at the plate
and this ball is leaned on to deep left
field did sam catch all of it yep
three run homer here come the rockies
it's a one-run game
just said a second ago the only thing
that's different was a home run sam
coming through
for hilliard his 13th of the year
the rockies are with their run
0-2 on chrome
clifford is ready looks back at story
and now the pitch and got him
he's out on strikes on the check swing
down the ending
so cronk couldn't hold back on the swing
remember he took two strikes to allow
story to steal and then a check swing
strike three
marshall trying to bun his way on pops
it up it drops down and he's aboard
there it is dalton varsio
with that speed another bunt hit
three defenders on that first base side
against calhoun who hits it over there
rogers makes a terrific play
story can't hang on and everybody's safe
brandon rogers made a nice play just to
get to that they had a play on varsha
with second but story couldn't get a
glove on it
slider see later how about that pitching
for gilbreth gilbert says no problem
strikes out three in a row
dom batting for the first time tonight
and this ball's lifted a pretty deep
right field way back and gone
game tying home run dom nunez
how do you like that
touch him old time dom nunez the
right-hander jb went delkin on in the
ninth inning and what is now a 7-7 game
here's the one-two and rogers lines this
toward right-center field and it's going
to get down and go to the wall
rogers in a second with a one out double
three hit night for brendan
that's hive ball four
so first and second one out trevor story
two aboard one out in a tie game in the
ninth he goes fastball lie to center
field base hit rogers will score
blackman on his way to third the throw
toward the plate cut off
trevor story comes through and gives the
rockies an 8-7 ninth inning lead
cronin's already driven in a run tonight
two for four
and this ball is
gonna go to first charlie got the big
jump a hesitation by perdomo
and it's another run batted in for crone
and the rockies lead it 9-7
one finger went down for nunez 0-2 see
you later mission accomplished
what an unlikely remarkable win for the
colorado rockies tonight
down 7-0
they come back and win nine to seven
trevor story gets the uh game-winning
hit in the ninth that's appropriate as
well and again the rockies
with the largest deficit they've ever
overcome in a road game win it 9-7